I'm going back to uh UK in June but last
time I was right here in Dublin yeah I
didn't know this someone handed me a
drink and it's a Guinness but with uh
like uh what was it some sort of current
is it called current yeah black currant
black currant it's like a black cherry
like yeah fruity thing apparently you
don't do that it's delicious don't do
that out there but they could tell
because my bear was purple and they were
booing I'm like what the hell are they
doing like your drink I'm like oh really
and like we don't do that out here I'm
like oh but who gave it to you the
bartender it's a bartender there was
articles how come the bartender doesn't
know what they do I think you know maybe
you could bring your own bartender like
he brings a chef that's what that's the
move